but first after five days a dozen
witnesses and 30-plus hours of testimony
was analyst the impeachment hearings
ended up a total bust
and despite public opinion turning
against them
the Democrats are so far out on the
ledge that I think they feel as if they
can't back away from moving forward now
they're likely considering the following
articles of impeachment
the first one is this generic abuse of
power the focus remains on the
president's stunning abuse of power that
relates to his pressuring a foreign
government to target an American citizen
for political gain he doesn't even seem
like he believes it of course none of
the witnesses that the Democrats
produced actually had direct evidence of
anything approaching stunning let alone
an abuse of power President Trump never
told me directly that the aide was
conditioned on the meetings resna didn't
come up or the Biden's or any of these
investigations no I did not did you ever
talk to President Trump in 2019 no I
have not and you were not on the call I
was not on the call second Democrats
could charge bribery my colleagues seem
to think unless the prison says the
magic words I hereby bribe the
Ukrainians that there's no evidence a
bribery that is soliciting a bribe and
that isn't a pizza bowl offense the
devastating testimony corroborated
evidence of bribery there is a new stuff
there is no evidence of robbery it's
patently absurd even congressmen will
hurd by the way Republican who's
retiring and he's not a huge fan of the
president rejected that argument during
yesterday's hearing an impeachable
offense should be compelling
overwhelmingly clear and unambiguous and
it's not something to be rushed or taken
lightly I've not heard evidence proving
the president committed bribery Oh again
it's just it's just I mean I'd laugh if
it weren't so bad for the country
now the third potential article of
impeachment contempt of Congress
article three in the Nixon impeachment
articles contempt of Congress you are
obstructing Congress on a roll and
Donald Trump goes way beyond Richard
Nixon well if hyperbole were an Olympic
event he'd be draped in gold right now
okay I think it's contempt for Congress
not contempt of Congress at this point
well Trump's been more forthcoming to
Congress than Obama of course when he
was under the spotlight he's got more
press events than more interviews made
himself more available certainly sent
out more tweets ridiculous and finally
Democrats could try to charge Trump this
perhaps is my favorite of the faux
charges obstruction of justice they keep
taking it to court and no we're not
going to wait till the courts decide we
can't wait for that because again it's a
technique it's obstruction of justice
this again is perhaps the most pathetic
charge of all and it's another sign that
the Democrats are just out of steam a
president invoking a time-honored
privilege like executive privilege his
legal right is now obstruction of
justice obstruction of Congress if so
then everybody out there you better
buckle up because politics is just going
to get uglier and uglier as time goes on
Devin Nunez perhaps said it best when
the Democrats can't get any traction for
their allegations of quid pro quo they
move the goalposts and accused the
president of extortion then bribery and
at last resort obstruction of justice
now none of this is working and I think
deep down shift Pelosi and their
impeachment backup singers I think they
all know it but in one final desperate
effort to win over a weary nation the
chairman of the Oso Board did his best
to belt out a grand finale they were
silent when the president said that no
quid pro quo what do you want from Craig
no quid pro quo we can't just get over
it
where is Howard Baker
not using metaphors I think we need to
consult our conscience I resisted going
down this path for a long time we are
better than that
I love the gavel at the end it makes it
really persuasive except it doesn't does
that sound like a man who is confident
that his hearings did the job were
really persuasive or did seem to you
like it was a performer begging the
audience for applause joining me now
Robert Rea former whitewater independent
counsel and Harmeet Dylan attorney and
Trump 2020 campaign advisory board
member Robert the White House is of the
mind tonight that the house might not
even vote ultimately on impeachment but
I think they're pretty far out there on
that on that ledge to back away where do
you see this going I do to Laura I think
they are out on that ledge I mean the
only exit ramp would be consideration of
a possible censure resolution that's one
that's been often discussed in
connection with impeachments through our
history throughout our history but
generally speaking there doesn't appear
to be an appetite for that and I think
here the Democrats are too far out on a
limb appealing to the interests of the
progressive wing of the party and I
think speaker Pelosi is signaled that
she's got to go down this road for fear
that if she does and she jeopardizes her
speakership after me after the 2012
elections I mean when you when you hear
charge after charge the goalposts
shifting when they weren't getting the
public opinion polling that they wanted
they focus-group this at one point over
in the DCCC Democratic campaign a
congressional campaign committee they
were they were focused group using a
focus group to determine what the proper
article of impeachment should be and so
is there any surprise that Adam Schiff
is up there desperately trying to
conjure up all this emotion to close it
out yesterday well now I'm not surprised
because there are no facts to support
this effort but you would think that he
might have learned from Jerry Nadler
'he's belly-flop during the Muller
investigations and hearings that you
have to be prepared you have to make
sure your witnesses can
liver and his witnesses one after the
other are writing checks that you know
did not deliver on the impeachment
promise and so if I'm Nancy Pelosi
tonight I'm feeling very worried about
my prospects because she has now painted
herself into a corner and she has to do
something or she'll lose her position
and her party will lose at the polls but
you know it's going to be a dud and dead
on arrival in the Senate floor now
Robert one more point I want to go back
to that issue of obstruction of justice
because again they're frantic you know
in their efforts to tie this back to
Nixon because people think if it's like
Nixon it's got to be really bad and he's
going to resign then we're gonna be
happy so they know what's obstruction of
justice because he's he would invoke an
executive privilege to not appear before
the committee how dangerous a precedent
would that set moving forward Robert
well it's horrible because this is an
intro branch dispute and since when is
filing a lawsuit could that ever be
considered an act of obstruction of
justice I mean that really quite frankly
is a ridiculous notion that's an appeal
to the to a to another branch of
government a court to make a
determination as to whether or not a
privilege applies you can argue about
whether or not it's appropriate to file
a lawsuit but the contention that merely
by filing a lawsuit that that's
obstruction of justice is a ridiculous
notion yeah Nancy Pelosi made it clear
that she's not going to court
she Oh should only we don't have time
for that but if it's such a critical
issue for the country to wrestle with
for Congress to wrestle with but should
go to court because she'd be confident
she would win and she would want the
legal precedent would she not harm meat
on this pretty well well the court
system is part of our branches of
government and it's an integral part and
it's part of the due process system and
so I think she's she's just whistling
past the graveyard Laura she knows that
she doesn't have the goods and a court
would kick her out because it's not
there there there isn't the evidence to
support what they're trying to do here
so again Laura this is a political
process that's how the founders made it
and all of these Democrats need to be
thinking a couple of steps ahead as to
what happens when the voters who are
clearly board turned off or other
you know kind of revolted at this
prospect of these Democrats spending the
time on this and not on the people's
work what who's gonna be held
accountable it's not gonna be Donald
Trump
Robert Republicans now say at least the
White House is saying to the counsel's
office in various reports that they want
a Senate trial these proceedings have
been anything but fair
the Senate has an opportunity to fix
that I am confident they will and I look
forward to them completing the job that
we could have done here now apparently
the president is saying I want a trial
but Robert is this something the GOP
itself should want I don't think so look
I think that the trial in the Senate is
mostly about a deliberation over whether
or not the president should be removed
from office the evidence really is
already in I mean I I could foresee for
example Lindsey Graham through the
Judiciary Committee subpoenaing hunter
Biden and getting deposition testimony
but recall the the Clinton impeachment
there wasn't live testimony before the
United States Senate there were a
limited number of depositions and that
evidence was shared with the Senators
but mostly an impeachment of proceeding
before the Senate is a trial proceeding
a deliberation the the president would
present a case in the sense that there
would be a you know statements as would
the impeachment managers who would act
on behalf of the house but live
testimony is not what I imagined that we
would see before the United States
Senate and I think finally after a
couple of weeks of this since the
Republicans have control of the chamber
I would imagine a motion to dismiss
would be properly filed and considered
and we would you know end this and
short-circuit it without the the the
president even having to put on a
defense
Harmeet as a speaking of this they're
talking about the Lindsey Graham opening
this probe he's chairman of the House I
mean a Senate Judiciary Committee a
probe into Biden barrese mom now he's
demanding that the State Department turn
over all the communications among former
Vice President Biden hunter Biden in
Ukraine you know this is
in response to these allegations that
Biden remember pushed to fire that
prosecutor general mr. Shokan just to
end an investigation of that company
that employed his son paid him seventy
eighty thousand dollars a month
here's how Biden reacted to this today I
am disappointed quite frankly I'm
angered by the fact he knows me he knows
my son he knows there's nothing to this
Trump is now essentially holding power
over him that even the Ukrainians
wouldn't yield to who Lindsey is about
to go down in a way that I think he's
going to regret his whole life what do
you say to him I I'm just embarrassed by
what you're doing
Harmeet Joe Biden who who talked about
punching in a reference to domestic
violence the other night said he's
embarrassed for Lindsey Graham Yeah
right I mean Lindsey Graham has not
beholden to the president Lindsey Graham
has stood up to the president when he
feels that's appropriate and this is
entirely inappropriate inquiry and
anybody who knows the Sun I mean you can
just see the soap opera playing out on
television to know that there is
definitely something fishy about that
guy ever gating eighty thousand dollars
a month for anything but you know Biden
is I don't think thinking very clearly
about how this looks from afar and that
brings me back to the the Senate these
tenders have a conflict of interest lore
a lot of the Democratic senators are
going to be grandstanding for the
cameras and mugging and having nothing
to do with you know whether this is
really a I think this is an important
point and Robert we got to go but isn't
it true that the Senators cannot speak
that's why I trial they don't speak they
just sit there like potted plants
there's a real quick trial but not
outside I mean I mean it's it's all
gonna be talking for the cameras of
course you're absolutely right Robert
right they can't during the proceeding
they don't say anything that's correct I
mean again largely this is a
deliberative proceeding which is to
arrive at a verdict about whether or not
to remove the president from office and
rapine stress and the duck and the
Democrats don't have the votes so you
know what are we doing yeah the
Republicans think it's good for them but
I think you never know what's gonna come
up and and one of these everybody should
have their interests on the best
interest of they are their eyes on the
best interest of the country yeah Robert
I'm a great to see it tonight